[Music]
see of Thieves conveys nature's beauty
and wrath with aplomb and sailing across
the open ocean in a creaky vessel can
make you fall in love with its
impressive presentation this romantic
connection can be felt most when sailing
alone but sea of thieves is primarily
designed to be played with a trusty crew
doing so allows you to revel in
buffoonery and appreciate the value of
teamwork delivering an entirely
different perspective on what it means
to be a pirate these awesome moments
make the initial hours of the game feel
like you're embarking on a special
journey but this love affair is quickly
tested both by the game itself and other
players some of whom on PC are already
employing hacks to put your interactions
on uneven footing see if these is just
that a game that belongs to conniving
robbers who despite gaining no prize
other than the cosmetic items see fit to
disrupt well main players this is to be
expected to a degree and I'd be lying if
I said there weren't moments when I
screwed over someone else for the sheer
delight of asserting power and punishing
another player's naivety even so
sabotaging others didn't make me happy
for long and certainly didn't provide me
with anything meaningful enough to
warrant developing my own underhanded
side to that end playing as a trusting
do-gooder is often more fulfilling
though the Afro mentioned aggressors and
a surprising lack of depth to missions
curtailed this approach - after 30 hours
I'm left wondering when I'll jump back
into the game again a part of me feels
like I've seen it all another part of me
knows I'm using that as an excuse to
take a break from grinding through
another shallow quest in search of gold
the ostensibly ultimate goal is to
become a legendary pirate to reach that
level of notoriety you have to increase
your reputation with the games three
factions each to the maximum level by
completing a series of quests
these include defeating reanimated
skeletons of fallen pirate captains
digging up buried treasure and capturing
very specifically colored pigs and
chickens
if hunting small animals sounds boring
you're right on the money the fact that
it's a dominant activity in the game is
mildly baffling the other two pursuits
have their charms at first but once you
realize that the basic requirements of
each factions quests are forever the
same monotony quickly sets in given that
maybe it's not surprising that people
opt to rob others of their treasures and
as a means to impress factions again the
only reward for earning reputation even
for sticking it out and becoming a
legendary pirate is looking fancy new
guns are always only as good as the ones
you started out with an expensive attire
is designed to impress not to protect
you from harm any better than a basic
set of rags this might be enough to
inspire some people to stick it out
through the repetitive quests and often
frustrating engagements with other
players but I can't imagine why a dash
of color here and a new collar there
would inspire the ardent perseverance
required all that being said I can still
appreciate the dynamics of working with
a friendly crew and if I ever return a
sea of thieves in the near future it
will be to recapture those special
moments there's almost no better way to
kill time during a voyage than to act
like an idiot on deck chugging grog to
the point of vomiting is a regular
occurrence as is catching it in a bucket
to toss on a crew mate clouding their
vision with bile and booze the drunker
you get the less stable you are and
higher the chance that you'll
accidentally stumble overboard much to
the delight of everyone
[Music]
coordinating with a team of three other
sailors to properly stock your vessel
and manage its equipment is the most
immediate venue for skill development
but the only time you're truly tested is
when engaging in battle against another
ship where you're required to manage the
speed and orientation of your boat load
and fire cannons on deck and patch up
holes from enemy fire before your ship
fills with water and sinks it's great
when you can fend off an attacker but
conversely demoralizing and stripped of
your riches just because you sign up for
that risk when you dedicate yourself to
the game doesn't mean losing all your
treasure is any less of a hit to your
enthusiasm when another crew takes over
your ship
see if thieves offers other notable
surprises such as the appearance of a
cloud skull in the sky with glowing eyes
signaling a raid consisting of waves of
enemies nearby you can tackle these well
enough with a four person crew but are
free to team up with others as well just
be prepared for them to turn on you when
it comes time to collect the bounty of
treasure
you may also run into the infamous
massive Kraken NIT voyage a moment that
is exciting the first time around but
subsequently one worth avoiding
the Krakens giant octopus arms rise out
of stained black water really a trick to
prevent you from seeing that the Kraken
is just a group of disconnected arms
without a body in the middle its arms
can either grab your ship or pluck
sailors from the deck and you've got a
limited amount of time to pummel it with
cannon fire to free the would-be victims
in the end all you can do is damage it
enough so that it's links away a
deflating discovery that makes you think
twice about future engagements
especially given that there's no
tangible reward for your victory
[Music]
there may come a time when see if
thieves is able to entice me back and I
imagine that will be with a mix of new
mission types and hopefully the promise
of rewards that allow for new types of
interactions if not improve my
characters capabilities for now it's a
game that can be fun for a handful of
hours and played with friends and
something worth trying out if you happen
to have an Xbox gamepad subscription
even though it's hard to wholeheartedly
recommend I like enough of what I see to
hold out hope that things will
eventually improve as sea of thieves
continues to be patched and updated with
new content
[Music]
you